so first of all i'm sure you know this
already fans of this show
are loving you on this season is is it
nice to have such positive feedback from
die hard fans
oh my goodness i have never seen these
fans
know everything they notice everything
they notice
it's amazing they are the most i have to
say bravo's
fans and the fans of the housewives
um that they uh this is their show
boy they are devoted and i've never seen
anything like it yeah and i feel like
fans are really protective
too over the series and they just
absolutely love you
we have fun watching you how much fun
are you having on this show
i'm having a blast i laughed
i had a great time i cannot
i don't regret if i had to do it again i
would do
it it's an experience yeah and i had a
really positive experience i happened to
adore the girls um i felt
really very close and it was just
nice because during coba
during the whole pandemic you know
you're really
basically at home and um
i just felt really really good it felt
really good
that's so nice to hear um you know your
sisters kyle and kim have been on this
series from the start
what made you decide to finally join
this casa for all these years
well i was um harassed
by the producer and
the uh and kyle and they she would not
they would not give up they literally we
were back and forth for three months
and it was yes no no no no no no yes
maybe what
and then i talked about it with my
husband and we
really thought about it and he said
you know this would be a great
opportunity for you and kyle
i think go for it i love that
well you know we had a rough rough go
for
many years and um
also i didn't know what to expect going
into the show
because i don't watch the show
okay so what surprised you the most
about being part of this series
just just these women are very
very passionate um
i don't i don't think there's
any phonyness going on i was just
surprised at how
real and how things develop and i
figured people had earpieces and that
there were going to be
you know production people whispering in
this person's
ear that that that wouldn't work for me
and as a friend i wouldn't have to do
that but none of that went
down and it was a lot of fun because
it's a lot of work you start in the
morning
and then you have a little break and
then
it's lunch and then it's an activity
and then it's cocktails before dinner
at dinner and then the cocktails after
so
pace yourself and i want to clear one
thing
um the bottoms up was olive water
oh it was okay that they should go ahead
and drink a martini like that yeah
i'm more of a wine or a glass of
champagne girl
so my i appreciate that you know kyle
has talked about the highs and lows
between the
two of you how would you describe your
relationship now
it is wonderful it's really great we
talk
two three times a day and
we laugh and i just feel that she's very
supportive of me
and i've always been supportive of her
uh how do your kids feel with you being
on this series were they a little bit
hesitant at first and now that they've
seen you
are they all for it um
well they did not i knew that they
wouldn't like the idea so that's why i
kept it from them and certainly i'm not
going to say anything
until it's for real and
i hadn't even signed the contract during
the first episode
at the reits house it still hadn't been
there was so much
back and forth i think i confused them
you know
and uh so i didn't say anything to the
girls
and then they found out people magazine
had confirmed it and one of their
friends called and they were walking
down in greenwich village new york
and uh that's how they found out oh wow
i've avoided them for
for a couple days and um
yeah so i have not talked to paris about
the show
she sent me a few memes the other day
she's i think she's on safari right now
okay oh wow i don't know that she's
been able to see the show but she's
definitely seen the memes
just by being online yeah well the memes
are hilarious and they're so funny and
she obviously knows them that people are
loving you on the series
they are so entertaining i have le i
have never laughed so hard
and it's weird to see yourself
i can only imagine it's in real life
yeah okay so who who had the strongest
reaction
then when they found out paris or nikki
well both of them you know once nicki's
the little
ring leader and so
once she makes a decision paris follows
whatever she says
so i think paris is cool with that and i
think nikki is now too
i had to ask her i asked her last week i
said you know three episodes have been
on if you had a chance to see it
she said yes james and i watched the
other night and we thought it was fine
it was very nice
oh good okay well that's nice to get
their support
now definitely on this show we've seen
tension between sutton and crystal
uh do you think that they will come
eventually to an understanding
i do because these ladies do i
what i admire is they'll they're
passionate in
how they feel and what's going on here
and and they they clash and then
they had to put it right behind them all
of a sudden
oh let's go dancing or they they just
they know how to put it behind them and
move forward
yeah and that hold grudges that's nice
and that's how you know you can
people have ups and downs and
friendships right so it's nice that they
can actually put that behind them
i've talked to and treated the way i've
seen
some of the situations
right i'm just very sensitive
i would not be happy nope that makes
sense
um do you see yourself sticking around
and showing up on more seasons
um i i don't i'm you know i've
considered this i've done it it's
been an incredible experience
i have a full plate and i'm
i have a wedding to plan and um
you know i have a husband who is very
busy and i'm very involved with him
his business and i don't know
you know we have four children we have
grandchildren
so busy there's another like 16
episodes and let's just see
we'll see yeah all right well you know
your fans are crossing their fingers so
we will see we're fine waiting until we
make a decision
but i do want to talk about wedding
planning with paris how's that going
well it's it's great uh we just need to
get her to get back from her trip so
that we can sit down and
figure out the venue and the vibe
yeah and is she good at letting you help
her make decisions or does she like to
kind of
make the final decision paris would be
happy as i've said
and it's true if you had teddy bears
unicorns
and white flowers dangling from the
season
from the ceiling and uh hot dogs tacos
hamburgers and sushi she's very
easy breezy oh i love that okay now i
want to come to this wedding this is
awesome
and just to wrap just to wrap things up
you know i know there's so much back and
forth
coming on the show what you're going to
do did a certain housewife from even a
different
city give you a piece of advice or is
there anyone that you know you kind of
listen to their wisdom who've been on
the show already
um jill zarin reached out
um i i did reach out to bethany
yeah bethany i've known a long time
bethany used to work for me so i thought
i'm not going to ask kyle because kyle's
not going to say
anything that's going to pull me off
so i figured bethany's the perfect one
so
i texted her and she says ask kyle
[Laughter]
oh really i thought um but then a few
weeks later she
called to me to wish me a happy mother's
day and so awesome
well congrats on this series love that
everyone's loving you and yeah you are
busy so uh yeah just enjoy the rest of
your day
and the rest this year so many exciting
things popping up for you thank you so
much
you